[Music]
hey guys
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
like i've done in the past for voldemort
snape and mcgonagall
i'm going to be listing dumbledore's top
5 most powerful spells and abilities
first things first dumbledore is
undoubtedly the most powerful wizard to
have ever lived
comparable only to voldemort and
possibly grindelwald
we'll have to wait and see how the jewel
ends up to confirm this
but despite being intensely powerful
dumbledore was also known for being all
too modest
when it came to his magical prowess in
fact in the first book
there is even a moment where it's
partially suggested that dumbledore is
in fact
definitively the most powerful sorcerer
of all time or at least that he
possessed the inherent capability
to be the most powerful if he so desired
mcgonagall says to dumbledore
but you're different everyone knows
you're the only one you know
alright voldemort was frightened of you
flatter me
said dumbledore calmly voldemort had
powers i will never have
to which mcgonagall replies only because
you're too
well noble to use them what this tells
us is that dumbledore has a higher
overall power threshold than
voldemort and in the book events of the
ministry atrium duel
dumbledore clearly walks all over
voldemort this is shown a little bit
differently in the movie
however it's worth mentioning that
damodar did possess
the elder wand at that time which gave
him a substantial edge
and while dumbledore is more powerful
than voldemort it's hard to imagine how
powerful he could have been
if he too had plunged into the world of
dark magic
voldemort's level of power was achieved
by any means possible
with no exceptions his pursuit of power
was filled with ignorance
showing disregard for the consequences
of the pursuit of dark magic
he delved further into the darkness than
anyone before him and became powerful
because of it
but perhaps at too greater cost in the
pursuit of power he lost himself however
even though he plunged himself into
magic as much as possible voldemort at
no point in the books or films
appears to exhibit magical ability but
far exceeds or outweighs
dumbledore dumbledore while staying on a
relatively light
path with the exception of his younger
years still reached
new heights when it came to magical
ability while at school
dumbledore's magical abilities
consistently turned heads
particularly his skills surrounding
charms and transfiguration
he also did exceptionally well on his
newts and griselda marchbanks
a professor working for the wizarding
examinations authority
remarked that albus was able to do
things with a wand she had never seen
before
in addition to being a charms and
transfiguration master dumbledore was
also an expert practitioner of elemental
magic
in his duel against voldemort in the
ministry atrium we see his elemental
expertise shine through
however i think that it would be a safe
bet to say that there truly isn't a
subject or
area of magic where dumbledore is
lacking he is truly a master of
transfiguration
charms potions elemental magic
occlumency
and more he is the exception to the
phrase jack of all trades
master of none as he was a master of all
starting at the top of the list it's
back here
just kidding number five silent
apparition
the ability to apparate is powerful
magic and difficult to achieve
but it is by no means unique to
dumbledore however what would be
considered extreme mastery of apparition
is the ability to apparate silently the
only other known wizard to achieve equal
mastery of this ability
is dumbledore's dark rival voldemort a
silent apparition is the exact same as
regular apparition
with the exception that it is
exceedingly quiet
the ability to operate is of course a
means of transportation
in the wizarding world allowing you to
instantly transport or teleport
to a desired location the ability to
travel anywhere
in an instant without making a sound is
a truly invaluable and powerful ability
earning its place on this list number
four occlumency
occlumency is the practice of magically
closing one's mind
against legitimacy which involves
navigating through people's minds
to access their thoughts and feelings
sometimes even influencing them
like lord voldemort dumbledore is a
master oklahomans
and legitimates but because of his
nature he is far more likely to
primarily use the former
at the basic level an occlumens in the
event of a mind infiltration
will simply clear their mind so that it
is blank and empty
this ability gets far more advanced when
the oculum changes their thought
patterns
in order to confuse the legitimates
creating faux memories and a contrived
mentality
that is intended to deceive the
legitimates occlumency is considered to
be a rare and
difficult skill and dumbledore is
probably one of the best at it
given that infiltrating his mind was
seemingly never even an option
for voldemort number three expecto
patronum
the disillusionment charm and charms in
general
dumbledore is a master of charms and
uses them almost excessively
throughout the books and films his
ability to perform charms eventually
earned him the title of grand sorcerer
later in life dumble is perhaps the most
adept wizard
at casting the notably difficult
patronus charm and is said to hold the
power of choosing which type of patronus
he wants to cast corporeal or
incorporeal which as far as we know
no other witch or wizard is able to do
often if you can think of something
there will be a charm for it
and if you're in search of how to
perform said charm then damodal is your
man
another equally useful charm that
dumbledore is able to cast
is the disillusionment charm which
causes the target to take on the exact
colours
and textures of their environment much
like a chameleon
the result is that you are basically
invisible some other notable charms that
dumbledore is able to perform
include arrestor momentum or the slowing
charm which slows the falling velocity
of an object
as well as pure totem locomotor which
brings inanimate or unmoving objects to
life
number two transfiguration dumbbell is
of course a master at transfiguration
which is defined as the art of changing
the form or appearance
of an object or person dumbledore was
the professor of transfiguration at
hogwarts
for a period of time and in his
schoolboy days exhibited extreme
comprehension of transfiguration when
taking his newts
transfiguration is a particularly
complex branch of magic
that can go quite wrong if performed
incorrectly there are several branches
of transfiguration
most notably cross species
transfiguration and human
transfiguration
it has been heavily speculated that
transfiguration is a more difficult
skill to master
than something like charms despite
charms having a wide range of functions
i think the most impressive display of
transfiguration that we've seen from
dumbledore was when
during his duel with voldemort he
transfigured shards of glass shot at him
into sand really impressive stuff number
one
elemental magic over the course of the
books and films i think that one of
dumbledore's abilities really stands out
in both his jewel against voldemort in
the ministry atrium and his encounter
with the inferi
we see dumbledore continuously pull out
all sorts of tricks
from up his sleeve and when i think
about what dumbledore's most powerful
ability is
it's got to be his mastery of the
elements first we've got firestorm
otherwise known as lasso of flames which
is an incantation that produces a large
ring of fire
from the cast as wand when the caster
moves the ring of fire moves with them
which will effectively ward off anyone
trying to hurt them while the ring of
fire circles them
the caster also holds the ability to
shoot individual jets or balls of flames
at their opponents this ability pairs
well with partis temporis
which allows a gap in the flames for the
caster to safely pass through
dumbledore used this spell to put off
the masses and ferry who were guarding
the horcrux
even in his weakened state this spell
proved to be more than enough
to serve its purpose another good
example of dumbledore's mastery of the
elements was his use of water
in his jewel against voldemort in the
ministry atrium dumbledore at one point
produces some sort of
hydrokinetic spell and it's clearly
magic unlike anything we've seen before
i think that what we witness in the
books and films really only scratch the
surface of dumbledore's power
but from what i've seen these seem to be
the most powerful
what do you guys think do you agree with
this list is there something that i've
missed
if so please let me know down in the
comment section below
until next time you're a wizard hurry
[Music]
you